the name of pocket gems really speaks to
what we do which is make beautiful
things for your mobile device we try to
make games that appeal to everybody
innovation in mobile gaming right now is
really important the social aspect to it
seems to be really really important it's
more engaging people love to be able to
interact with other people
we're dragons was our first online
gameplay so server scalability is really
important in minutes or hours you might
have hundreds of thousands of players
playing your game if you don't have the
server infrastructure your servers just
just gonna explode
Google cloud platform allows us to be
able to scale automatically we don't
even have to think about that if you
needs more server it spins up servers
when it doesn't need them anymore it
just spins them down in a matter of
seconds our game is evolved drastically
from the time of launch and we used
Google App Engine to build a be testing
tools where we could put out different
features as we saw when people engage
with and what they wanted Google App
Engine and the analytic tools behind it
were able to help us make really good
decisions on how to evolve the game over
time as a service world cloud platform
allows us to focus on what we love doing
the best games we can the games they're
going to delight our players your
back-end just works it's almost magical
pocket gems is really excited to be part
of this revolution where a billion
people's first experience with the
Internet and with mobile is playing
products like ours it's real privilege
to be making our products being the ones
that are out there and bringing on this
change
you